une première mondiale en chirurgie
digestive au chu de strasbourg une
intervention réalisée par un robot
baptisé zeus et qui est piloté
uniquement à la voix un système à
commande vocale qui s'inscrit dans les
travaux de l'institut européen de
téléchirurgie dirigée par le professeur
marescaux la précision du robot est
incroyable alors que le chirurgien lui
est confortablement assis à sa table de
travail
dominique dumas is up mobylette stop
ce chirurgien elle vient de parler en
anglais à ses instruments en fait pour
la première fois au monde
il s'est adressé à dieu ce un robot
chirurgical piloter à la voix qui vient
d'effectuer ses premières interventions
pour une opération digestifs chez
l'homme le professeur marescaux et son
équipe du centre hospitalier
universitaire de strasbourg ont ainsi
mis à profit une technologie qui au
départ avait été mise au point
spécialement pour la chirurgie cardiaque
ici il s'agit de l'ablation d'une
vésicule biliaire chez l'homme une
caméra a été placé dans le ventre d'un
patient l'abdomen a été préalablement
gonflé sur une simple commande à la voix
humaine
la caméra couplé à dieuze explore avec
une précision millimétrique les
différentes parties de la visite hull la
commande vocale se limite pour l'instant
à la caméra mais pourrait également
s'appliquer à l'avenir aux instruments
dont la taille n'excède pas les 3000
hymne parfait
les gestes humains sont analysés par
l'informatique et reproduit par des bras
articulés ce type d'opération devrait
permettre des progrès dans la chirurgie
à distance que plusieurs équipes
médicales dans le monde essaye de
perfectionner